the Joe Rogan experience yeah well you
guys had some crazy fights but the
craziest one was probably the one where
the guy landed in the middle of the Ring
the guy with the parachute with the what
was that guys what did he call himself
the Phantom Man fan that's right he had
a fan that was powering his parachute
and he literally landed in the ring that
was an outdoor arena in Vegas is that
what it was sure was and a mate and held
the fight up about thirty minutes that
was crazy
oh yeah at that time I had him hurt yes
and like that and it saved it yeah well
you had them hurtin and everybody got
cold
I mean you cooled off I mean it almost
seems like they should have cancelled a
fight well you know it was half of the
fight you did they guess a fight they
were had to pay us again what there's a
picture up there like look at that what
was going through your mind when you saw
that guy land on the ropes like that
well it shocked me and then because when
they did the light started like just
saying
Curtis Mayfield had just got paralyzed
but same thing with the thing fell the
old lights fell on them yeah yeah Curtis
Mayfield he got paralyzed that was yes
oh wow so you thought maybe the lights
were about to fall well yeah and now
we're trying to make sure that I can
make that quick step get in I get out
right right right yeah yeah so this guy
once you finally realize that it was a
guy on a parachute with a fan behind him
how mad were you you know if I can keep
my mind on him
I gotta keep my mind already buddy my
mind you know you know you had to have a
one track - you gonna be real good we're
gonna be the best
you haven't had that one track mind yeah
yeah it's not something you could pay
attention to but it was it hard to get
your mind back into it after the settle
and they had to clear the guy out and
arrest him and clean the ring out and
everything no III stay focused and my
whole thing is that I you know I felt
that I won the first half right
now I got this nice hair why did it take
a half hour to get that guy out of there
you know you know you know rid of both
wife were there she was afraid she had
to leave and all this sorry so many
thing happen cuz the guy happened to
come over Farrakhan and and as all these
people they don't beat the po-man in the
head I'll knock them out like this out
to me he got a really good beating for
coming in I hope he did big yeah
is he still in jail no no I'm not a pass
now oh he's gone yeah well oh well I
guess that's his legacy well you know
you [ __ ] up your fight that's his
legacy wait you're right
but I won yes you did yeah
[Applause]